well i mean magical thinking is is sort  of  necessary for the suspending of  disbelief in order to have faith in the  first place isn't it i mean magical  thinking in a managed way is that's a  part of the whole treatment  i don't perceive magical thinking and  religion as the same thing because  magical thinking  magic is trying to and i forgot who said  this i'm quoting somebody here yeah  magic is an attempt to control the  godhead uh-huh magic is a way to control  god right it's about creation yeah faith  is the  is the opposite faith is acceptance yeah  so it's it's magical thinking is  actually it's completely antithetical to  my faith